I was always in discomfort from the time
I was my first memories are of a
stomachache and not being able to digest
my food and so I knew it was food and I
told the doctors I went to sick kids and
I said you know what if Michaela eats
oranges her toast Wells and they were
like oh yeah they kind of wrote it down
but they were not interested you know
Jordan and I you guys were at home and
we whisper we whispered each other you
know what I think we're getting younger
I mean that doesn't happen like gum
disease doesn't get better arthritis
doesn't just go away depression doesn't
just
evaporate I have a normal life for the
first time in my life